hi I'm Chelsea Handler and I'm going
undercover on the internet today okay
this is actually me Instagram hmm why
hasn't that hair come back in style we
were real hair stylist back then I know
girl I know but it's the ozone layer we
have to look out for it it did take a
lot of effort to make a right angle out
of your hair as a child in New Jersey I
had to get up at 5:45 in the morning to
be ready to leave my house at 7:45 and
what came between me and my Aqua Net
during that time didn't see the light of
day because I had to get to school with
my hair like this and it couldn't move
all day it had to be stiff you know what
I'm talking about a jean barber where do
you get all of the great t-shirts great
question I have somebody who buys them
for me bad answer at lipstick in my
Valentino how are things going with the
dogs are they still [ __ ] I remember
you had some bonding issues in the
beginning they're so adorable thank you
for this question I like that people pay
attention to my lifestyle with my dogs
we have gotten closer the dogs now I
don't need to take them upstairs to my
room on leashes now I'd tell them to go
upstairs and they know to go upstairs
and they also use the doggie steps to go
up into my bed without the leashes so
that's progress because I'm not trapping
them in my bed anymore ready some people
call it Rudy who came up with that name
reddits but it doesn't roll off my
tongue
why does Chelsea Handler like to get
naked so much I'll tell you a little
story I had a boyfriend who told me my
boobies were too big once and he told me
that I looked fat because my boobies
were too big and that it was inelegant
obviously I already know I'm inelegant
so I didn't need I had on a hat so once
I got away from that boyfriend and I
went to a doctor to get a consultation
about a breast reduction I had a doctor
look at me and say you are lucky to have
breasts like that people pay hundreds of
thousands of dollars he didn't say
hundreds of thousands I just put that in
his extra I don't think it's hundreds of
thousand dollars to get these but I
decided to start appreciating my breasts
and that's when I took my top off for a
year is Chelsea Handler and es
TJ oh yeah I know that thing what's that
test it's a test of personality test
barracks yeah exactly myers-briggs
epstein-barr whatever ESTJ sounds
familiar but I'm not positive where did
Chelsea Handler go in Iquitos
I was curious anyone knows where Chelsea
Handler went for her ayahuasca journey
her shaman was named Maximo oh I
wouldn't recommend it don't worry
who is Chelsea Handler what's her deal
UK vetted her she's a loudmouth blonde
woman with huge tickets okay so look out
brother especially if you're
uncircumcised and being from the UK it
sounds like you are too whatever my
favourite is it weird if I say I'm proud
of you because I am no that makes me
really happy thank you I'm proud of you
too I like that thank you
this is at chillon underscore I mean
Chelsea I want to hear your opinion on
dating younger men please don't hold
back
lol girl you don't need to write lol
you're better than that and younger man
yeah whatever you're into I mean younger
men to me I find expensive
it's kind of an onus you know they're
not the norm of their [ __ ] together you
have to kind of pay for things I'd like
to live like a very nice lifestyle and I
want the person I'm dating to be able to
keep up you know yeah I don't have to
pay for him I want him to be able to pay
for himself but if you want to be any
with younger guys go for it at janitors
Gym Agurs I love your dog what's their
breed surprise surprise I thought I was
rescuing to chow chow mixes I got their
DNA done 23andme and they are 60% ciao
one is 66 one a 67% ciao
the other 40% or 30-something percent is
Rottweiler that was unexpected for those
of you unfamiliar it's clora
what was Chelsea Handler like in high
school
well for starters she wasn't at high
school because I never went to class I
didn't think that the classroom was an
appropriate place for me to learn so I
decided to get a boyfriend and spend
most of my time with him driving around
in my brother's car that I used before I
had a license I had to make up the last
two years of high school in one year
because I lost complete credit for my
junior year for never showing up at all
so high school was a blur
next question how did Chelsea Handler
become a comedian
funny story I got a DUI when I was 21
and I got into a fight with the police
officer who arrested me by calling him a
racist
we were both white after that I went to
DUI classes for 12 weeks where they make
you get up and tell your story about how
you got a DUI and when I got up and told
my story I didn't want to get off the
stage because everybody was laughing so
hard and after that somebody said I
should become a stand-up comedian and I
thought [ __ ] it why not what does it
like to do mushrooms with Chelsea
Handler great question I'm having a
mushroom night Friday at my house in Bel
Air
if you know the address come on over
everybody's welcome it's fun I have a
full Wikipedia Handler was born in
Livingston New Jersey New Wave a jersey
as they say that in Spain the youngest
of six children of Rita Stoker a
homemaker and seymour handler a used car
dealer a used car dealer implies that
the cars were coming and going but
they'd came to our house and just stayed
so he never sold the cars he collected
them her American father is an Ashkenazi
Jewish person her German born mother who
came to the United States in 1958 was a
Mormon this is true handler has written
five books that have made the New York
Times bestseller list four of which have
reached number one that's wrong I've
written six books that have made the New
York Times bestseller list five of which
have reached number one but who's
counting
Instagram again at why it's mom at 21
what is your favorite edible chocolate
gummies what do you think of CBD oil
funny you mention that because I just
had 250 milligrams of CBD oil as soon as
I got to this building this morning and
I don't feel a thing so I'm not a huge
fan of CBD oil
I prefer mental high which is THC CBD is
just for me but I basically will take
any edible that anyone gives me at Kate
furyk Walker where did you eat in New
Orleans you had a place in your story
and now it's gone I don't remember
oh coke a croquette Coquette Coquette
yeah croquette sounds great
at Steph underscore superwoman do you
know that cows have emotions and like to
cuddle pigs are the other farm animal
that are very intelligent and mourn when
their mate dies no I didn't know that I
am DB trademark caustic commentary
self-deprecating humor sarcastic and
critical views of a list celebrities
that's correct
her favorite movie is Porky's 1981 I was
six
and yes that movie stayed with me I'm
forcefully expressing her political
beliefs I don't care how annoying or
loud I am it's important to be loud I
agree with that so much twitter at mujer
bummer ah great handle and I'm jealous
what the hell is a perfect night's sleep
well it's called an edible and good
night that's a perfect night's sleep for
me you really have to find your own
ghost girl were you hungover at 5 5 p.m.
or 5 years old you were hungover at 5
again at 5 of age I doubt it I was
probably pissing in a bad mood but I
don't think it had anything to do with
alcohol that point and at 5 p.m. you
I've been hungover if I can I want to
thank everybody for tuning in today to
find out what my answers to people with
questions on the Internet are or were or
whatever tense I'm supposed to be using
it was very important for me to spend
this time with you today and I want to
thank you for listening and I want to
thank you for learning